uh this is interesting because it's one
of those stories
where there is not one
simple understanding of the world that
tells us what we need to know
sometimes we need to hold sort of two
ideas that
might appear to conflict simultaneously
and we have a sort of
bifurcation maybe i would call it
in the united states right now in terms
of the republican party
where on the one hand donald trump is
still clearly the leader of the
republican party until proven otherwise
and yet he is rapidly sliding towards
online irrelevance now you might hear
that and say david sir
how could that be true how could trump
be irrelevant online
but be the revered holy leader of the
republican party
and the answer is something that we
learned through the 2020 democratic
primary which is that the real world
and the online world are two different
things which
remember when bernie sanders appeared to
be dominating twitter
twitter or um reddit
during the 2020 primary and yet joe
biden won the democratic primary in 2020
by quite a bit
we realized what happens online is not
necessarily reflective
of what's going on in the greater real
world
so on the one hand most republicans
still like trump most republicans want
trump involved in politics most
republicans want trump to run in 2024.
we see this in every poll most
republicans still believe trump did win
2020. most republicans say they would
follow trump to his own
third party if trump were to leave the
republican party most republicans say if
given the opportunity in 2024 they would
vote for donald trump again
but then look at what's happening online
thanks to being banned from twitter
facebook youtube and many other
platforms for his regular
uh rule breaking and incitements to
violence donald trump has been
relegated to his blog at donaldj
trump.com and that blog is having
essentially
zero impact we barely talk about it we
mentioned today trump's reaction
to the grand jury being convened against
them that's big news a grand jury
looking at whether a former president
committed crimes
but it's barely making news what donald
trump writes on his blog
remember that trump and his staff were
regularly
teasing how trump's new online
social media communication platform is
going to
revolutionize everything and put trump
back in the spotlight
it ended up being just a blog that
barely anybody is reading
and as the washington post now reports
online discussions of trump
have plunged to a five-year low in the
last week trump's website
attracted fewer estimated visitors than
the pet adoption website
petfinder and the recipe website delish
so the incredible sort of fork at which
we're arriving
is that while trump is clearly the
republican party's biggest star
at this point in time and many
republican lawmakers continue to pledge
endless loyalty to him
it is simply not translating to online
influence at all
overall online influence for trump is
down about 95
since january and down to its lowest
level since 2016.
his blog from the desk of donald trump
which they have been
so heavily promoting um sometimes the
blogs are only shared on facebook two
thousand times
we get sometimes two thousand shares or
more of a random video that we publish
to facebook so understand the the
scale of these numbers these are really
low numbers for a former president
so of course the real question is absent
his ability to make stories viral
is trump going to lose control of the
narrative as we get towards 2022.
how does this affect the republican
party in 2022 how does it affect the
republican party and trump in 2024
can trump wield the influence he wants
to wield and be the king maker he wants
to be in 2022
without that bully pulpit i don't know
that he can now in some sense trump may
realize already that he needs to do
something
because we have reports that he's
planning to
i guess get his old the dark blue uh 757
the boeing 757 airplane
he's planning to get it back into action
for so-called rallies
and for who the rallies will be and
when we we don't really know i do think
that if we close in on 2022
and trump starts doing his fly-in
rallies around the country
in support of republican candidates that
he's deemed to be
acceptable republicans that will get him
attention
because a former president on the
campaign trail gets attention that's
just the reality
but if you doubt at all the reach of
trump's influence today
look at what happened with liz cheney
liz cheney was removed from house
republican leadership
by republicans because she publicly
admitted hey guys trump just lost
he just lost she was with trump 93
of the time on voting it's not like
she's some liberal but she acknowledged
trump lost and she was kicked out of
republican leadership
that simply doesn't happen if donald
trump has lost control of his party
and that is continued proof that donald
trump for now has not lost control of
his party he's losing the bully pulpit
he's lost the majority of his online
influence but he has not lost control of
the republican party at least for now
one of our sponsors is magic spoon the
breakfast cereal
that tastes just like the sugary tasty
cereals we all loved as kids but
without the sugar and without the carbs
magic spoon is sweet and delicious with
zero grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein and only four
net carbs making it perfect for a
low-carb or
keto diet and very exciting news magic
spoon has released an awesome new flavor
birthday cake available for a limited
time only but you can still get cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter and
cinnamon
you can build your own variety pack our
team has tried every flavor
we've looked at each flavor really
strongly
and we keep asking them to just send us
more
you'll get five dollars off when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the coupon code pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video